when running we didn't think we
thought that I had
[Music]
just a job in puylagarde but
never never never cried never no
we were skills and at hand
[Music]
a kid not me they put me in  a
plane to go to the missions and jean-pierre
for the money admits that he was just a little
worried after bongo was following him worse and
the acute colleagues he was there to get
us back to
[Music]
he didn't come home the plane very crazy
past it was  what a person who
wouldn't tempt his four friends who
wouldn't make it theirs at first i was very
hard then awful bat nancy comes
i just told my little story
a good one if i could get a few
messages from people whose life was saved  life
I would be very happy
[Music]